desde Flickr. Vayamos a la derecha,
tomemos Flickr de la lista de opciones,
arrastrémosla a la línea de tiempo
y la colocamos donde deseamos;
de inmediato vamos a Flickr y empieza a mostrar imágenes
relacionadas a los tags. A mis desarrolladores
les gustan los ponis, por eso lo han puesto como tag por defecto.
Probemos algo diferente,
quizá algo más relevante hoy.
Son imágenes tomadas directamente desde la fuente.
Si volvemos en una semana
será completamente diferente,
dinámico, como la web, exactamente como la web,
todo tiene una fuente; si hacen clic en el enlace,
van directo a Flickr y ven la imagen fuente.
Todo lo que han visto hoy se construyó con los elementos
básicos de la web: HTML, CSS y JavaScript.
Significa que es totalmente remezclable. Significa también
que no hay software propietario. Se necesita
solo un navegador.
Imaginen si todos los videos que miramos en la web
funcionaran con la web, completamente remezclables,
vinculados con sus fuentes, interactivos
con todos los que los vieran.
Creo que Popcorn podría cambiar nuestra forma de contar historias
en la web y la forma de entender el mundo en el que vivimos.
Gracias. (Aplausos)